(people chattering)
- Thank you all for coming.
We're gonna start in a second.
Before we start, I would
like to thank all of you
for successfully braving
the storm last night
to talk about quantum science.
And we are so happy to
have so many researchers
from Yale alumni to people in the field
and also new generation of
students and researchers.
And so it's really, really
exciting to have all
of you here on site.
And now we can start
and we can have Michael Crair
the vice provost for research
and the William Ziegler,
Professor of Neuroscience
and Ophthalmology and Visual Science
kick off the conference.
Thank you very much.
- Thanks, Florian.
(audience clapping)
Hi, good morning.
I will be very brief
and begin actually to
reiterate, Florian's,
thanks to everybody who's come
to Yale from all over the
country and all over the world.
It's a tremendous tribute
to quantum science at Yale
and to Rob and Steve
and Michel, the influence
they've had on quantum physics
and quantum engineering over the course
of the last 20 plus years.
So thank you for coming.
We hope that you'll learn a lot
and that you will come to
appreciate not only the quality
of the science, quantum science
that's happened here at
Yale over the last 20 years,
but the future prospects
for quantum science,
which I think are tremendous.
So thank you for coming and I
look forward to the program.
So I want to next pause
and just remark on, I
expect this conference
to be extremely smooth and easy to follow
and quite efficient in its processes.
And for that we have to thank Florian
and the Yale conference and events teams.
He's put in a lot of effort as well
as the other folks in the
Yale Quantum Institute.
And I wanna make sure
whenever you have a chance,
please acknowledge his effort
and the quality of support he is
and actually the thoughtfulness
for what I think is gonna be just a
tremendous, tremendous conference.
So thank you Florian and team.
(audience clapping)
Just an another minute or two, Yale is...
Well, so those of you who
haven't been back to Yale
for a little while, you may
not recognize the building you're in.
That's because it's a new building.
And this spot was a building
that was called the Gibbs Building.
It was not a very high
quality science building.
It was torn down
and this new Yale science
building was built in its place.
It's a tremendous modern
facility for biological sciences.
The Department of Molecular Cellular
and Developmental Biology is
principally housed in this building.
In addition to this new
building, the Klein Tower,
which some of you might recognize
as the old Klein Biology Tower
was completely gut renovated.
And inside of it is a beautiful conference
facility on the 14th floor.
And actually dinner tonight will be in
that conference facility
on the 14th floor.
It's got a beautiful view of
New Haven, a 360 degree view.
The rest of that building is
now housed by the department
of, let's see, statistics
and data science, mathematics, astronomy,
and some physics faculty as well.
So it's a computational dry lab building,
is no longer a wet lab building,
but the sort of co-location
of those departments
with the new Institute
for the foundations of data science,
I think puts a nice focus on the role
and the import of data
science, broadly speaking,
computational science
in general in the future
of science at Yale.
So besides those important
building projects which have
occurred just over the last
couple years here at Yale,
I want to just note that
quantum science is a major focus
of growth for the university.
It was identified about five
years ago in a comprehensive
strategic plan by our
provost, Scott Strobel
and many of the Yale folks
here participated in,
in the development of that strategic plan.
But quantum science and
engineering in particular was
identified as an area
of future growth such
that we have now broken ground
on a new physical sciences
and engineering building complex
just to the north of here.
So it's the no part of northwest block,
part of this block of campus.
It's a very comprehensive
project that will juxtapose
and impart surround the
Wright Lab, which some
of you visited yesterday.
And in fact, the shovels
in the ground right now
for a new chemical safety
building, which we have
to build in order to prepare the site
for the physical sciences
and engineering building.
This will be a 300,000
square foot plus facility
for more than 40 faculty,
essentially doubling the faculty
in physical sciences
and engineering at Yale.
It includes a 12,000
square foot clean room,
modern clean room on bedrock,
large materials
characterization core facility,
a large imaging core facility,
and an advanced instrumentation
and development center,
which will all facilitate
quantum science, quantum
engineering, and material science.
So those of you who have
never been to Yale before,
Yale has changed dramatically
in the last few years.
And you can expect pretty
dramatic changes in the,
over the course of the next
five to 10 years, including
huge investments in quantum
science and engineering, largely
because of the tradition that
was established by Michelle
and Steve and Rob.
And so I wanna just pause here
and note the amazing science
that they've done over
the last 20 plus years
and the amazing science that they spawned
in the context of all of you here.
Many of you were children or grandchildren
and Michel, Rob and Steve,
and a new field of science,
really quantum computing I
think has emerged as a result
of their seminal contributions.
So it's amazing work.
It's wonderful to be able
to pause for a minute,
look back over the course
of the last 20 years,
what they've accomplished,
and also think together about
what we might accomplish over
the course of the next 10,
20 years, which I think
is essentially limitless.
So thank you to you
and I'm really looking forward
to the conference and for,
and so now I'd just like to
actually one more final comment.
So tonight at dinner, those
of you who make dinner.
There will be a model
and some posters, poster
boards about the new physical
science and engineering building complex
up on the 14th floor.
You can look down on the site
where that building will be built.
And tomorrow and Friday,
that model and posters will be
in the entry area to Marsh.
So you can look at it
and see what it is that we're planning,
which I think is quite spectacular.
Okay, so now pivot to the
science, which I'm sure,
which is what you're all
interested in learning about.
So I'm gonna introduce Steve Girvin.
Steve is a Eugene Higgins professor
of physics and applied physics.
He's also the former
vice provost for science.
The position I'm fortunate
to hold right now,
vice provost for research.
Steve has made seminal
contributions in quantum science,
including most of the theoretical
concepts that underlie the
engineering that you'll hear more about
over the course of the next three days.
So Steve, welcome
and thank you for providing
the introductory talk
for the conference today.
(audience clapping)
- Thanks very much, Mike.
We appreciate you being here
to introduce the conference
and also for the financial
support that the provost office
provided through the Flint fund.
So this is the start of
what we hope is an exciting conference.
And let me start by pointing out that
we're in the centennial
period of the invention
of quantum mechanics.
What exact year you think
is the hundredth anniversary
depends on whether you are
French, German or Austrian.
(audience laughing)
And 100 years to the week
that Vernor Heisenberg was on the island
of Helgoland inventing matrix mechanics.
There'll be a nice conference there,
so I commend that to you.
Okay, so I'm gonna talk about kind of
the brief history of circuit QED
and then talk about some new results
that we've been working on with
our many collaborators here in YQI.
So I want to give a
special thanks to the ARO
for their strong support
of this burgeoning field over
the last quarter century.
And it's been very important
to the history that I'm gonna
tell you about now.
And a lot of, you know,
the senior people will
know the history and,
but some of the younger
people don't know all of
the things shrouded in the midst of time.
So I thought it'd be fun
to go over that a bit.
And the field started with
classical mechanics
and the realization that the
Josephson equations told us
that the phase across a
superconducting junction
obeyed Newton's classical law of motion.
You could think of the phase
as the position of a particle
and it sits in a washboard potential.
If you have a current bias junction
and if it escapes from one of the wells,
it begins falling downhill.
And because the velocity
of the particle, the time
rate of change of the phase
is the voltage, you can
detect that velocity.
And for you young people who
don't know what a washboard is,
Mike Tinkham always used to say it's a
classical analog of a Joseph injunction.
(audience laughing)
So people started building
these circuits
and doing interesting things with 'em
in a world dominated by friction.
And Tony Leggett began asking
questions about Schrödinger cats and,
and you know, if this particle, if this
variable acts like the
position of a particle, could
that particle exhibit
macroscopic quantum behavior.
And so our heroes, John Clarke
and Michel Devoret and,
and John Martinez in
1985 decided to see if
that particle had quantized energy levels
inside these little potential wells.
And they did that by spectroscopy,
by kind of quantum jump spectroscopy,
where you shine microwaves at
the right transition frequency
and then the particle is
high enough up in the well
that it can tunnel out into
a finite voltage state.
So it's microwaves in
and low frequency
voltage measurements out.
And sure enough, they saw peaks
in the spectrum indicating
that this particle could
be quantum mechanical.
Then people started playing
with Cooper pair of boxes
and it's just a capacitor with
a bias voltage on it.
And it's a sufficiently small capacitor
that tuning this voltage could
change the average number of
Cooper pairs from end to end,
plus one, from a billion
to a billion plus one.
And if you choose the
bias voltage correctly,
those two states can be degenerate.
And because of the coherent
Josephson tunneling,
you can go into a superposition
of those two charge states.
And so unlike a normal junction,
the average charge would
change over a voltage range
that was controlled by the
coherent tunneling amplitude,
the coherent tunneling splitting
between those two charge states.
Also in Japan, Yasu
Nakamura was working on this
and he was doing microwave
measurements, again,
doing spectroscopy to see this splitting,
and then had a
destructive readout that
involved a complicated process in
which various voltages
were tuned in such a way
that a Cooper pair could break
and tunnel out acquiring some energy
to break from the bias voltages
and create a tiny tunneling
current in the circuit.
So again, microwaves in
and quite difficult,
noisy low frequency measurements
to see what happened.
But then in 1999,
Yasu wrote the paper, which
got me into the field.
I'd never heard of the
concept of quantum computing.
I didn't know there were
crazy people thinking about
this possibility.
And he did this amazing
experiment where he
with a half a million dollar
picosecond pulse generator
moved the bias point
of the circuit to the
degeneracy point so fast
that the system was then
in a coherent superposition
of the two eigenstates.
And it's the real time, you
know, it's the time domain
analog of Rabi oscillations
in a driven atom.
And here you can see these beautiful
Rabi oscillations,
but look at the timescale,
it's picoseconds
but still it was the
first time that this sort
of real time quantum
dynamics had been seen due
to this coherent splitting
and this is a, you know, I don't have time
to do the whole history,
so I'm just picking out a few highlights.
So this is Quantronium
from the Saclay group
and it was an artificial atom tuned
to a clock transition, to a place
where the splitting frequency
is first order insensitive
to the control knobs
that you can turn some
magnetic flux and some bias voltage.
And if you, you know,
a fundamental theorem
of engineering is that
if you can turn a knob,
the noise demon can also turn that knob.
So you want to be at a place
where you're first order is
insensitive to those effects.
And this was, I remember Rob
and I discussing this thing
just seemed to ring forever,
you know, half a microsecond.
It was incredible
how long the coherence was.
And this was the first observation
of Ramsey fringes in a solid state qubit.
And why was this important?
Because it's the thing we needed
to convince those pesky AMO physicists
that this was the real deal, okay?
This is their acid test for coherence.
So that was incredibly exciting.
and the experiment was done just
before Michelle moved to Yale
and really...
really moved things forward.
Hans Mooij in Delft
and also in some experiments
in collaboration with Yasu
developed a kind of dual to
these charge based qubits,
the flux qubit.
And John Martinez developed a
high fidelity readout.
It was 85%, it was like amazing
high fidelity for those days.
And it was going back
to his PhD thesis here.
You had two levels that were
deep enough in the well,
that they could be your qubit,
you could have a Rabi drive,
but then if you wanted to read it out,
you could check whether it was
in this state by exciting it
to this state and then having a tunnel out
and release a flood of energy
as the particle fell down the hill.
And that flood of energy was big enough
that he got this amazingly
high readout fidelity
for the time, 85%.
But unfortunately, when
you tried to do this
with two qubits, that amazing flood
of energy wiped out the other qubits.
So in the end it was too destructive,
but it was a real advance in
terms of readout fidelity.
Then coming back to New Haven
with a couple people who
are here in the room,
the Transmon Qubit, sort of the
world's simplest thing, just
a little dipole antenna
with the two halves connected
by a Joseph injunction.
It's not so little for an
atom, it's a millimeter across
the transition dipole
moment is several Cooper
pairs moving a millimeter,
which is a lot bigger than the
transition dipole moment of,
of sodium, for example.
And it had this wonderful feature
that it was exponentially insensitive
to offset charge noise.
And you know, people
that didn't experience those early days
won't understand why I had
PTSD looking at those old slides about
that involved charge.
So there's just stuff in the
substrate that moves around
and we can't fix that,
but we can make a qubit
that's insensitive to that.
It's an artificial atom with
atomic number 10 to the 12,
and yet the spectrum is
simpler than that of hydrogen
and it has a comparable quality factor.
Nowadays many people are making
high fidelity gates.
Here's one example from
Will Oliver's group,
or two examples, a controlled
phase gate through a coupler
between two transmons
and even higher fidelity gates between two
flexonium qubits with a transmon coupler.
So it's just been tremendous progress.
You'll hear more from other
people during the week.
And in Rob's dual rail talk on Friday,
I think you'll also see some
amazing fidelity numbers.
And you know, a key part of the
the engineering is that you
need quantum limited amplifiers
to detect the very tiny signals that
come out of these systems.
And there are many people, many
of whom are in the audience
who contributed to this, Conrad is...
is using them now to search
for dark matter axions
with our colleagues in the
Wright lab here at Yale.
And Michelle
and Zako used the very high
efficiency measurements to,
to catch and even reverse a
quantum jump in mid-flight.
So really very important
engineering developments.
Okay, so now onto really circuit QED.
So we know that QED is
really the study of the
effect of vacuum fluctuation.
So the quantization
of the electromagnetic field in the world.
And it has many effects
that you learn about not at the beginning
of your quantum mechanics course,
but certainly in graduate school.
It leads to spontaneous emission
of the first excito state
of hydrogen in 1.5 nanoseconds.
It renormalizes the mass of
the electron, gives a splitting
between the lamb shift between the
nominally degenerate states
of the hydrogen atom.
And the engineering we're trying to do is
to change the spectrum of
the vacuum fluctuations
by putting them between mirrors
or even inside a superconducting
box if it's microwaves.
And by changing that spectrum,
you can engineer new properties
and in particular you can
have the Purcell effect to
suppress the spontaneous
emission of the artificial atom
by not having any modes in the
cavity at that frequency.
That doesn't work in
macroscopic optical systems
because it can still radiate this way.
But inside a box, if you take
a Transmon in free space,
it has a spontaneous emission lifetime
of a hundred nanoseconds,
can be a thousand times
or more longer inside one of these boxes.
So that's very important.
So here's the original gang
with the first experiment,
it's inside a shielded copper box
because we were sure that
all those cell phones
that were being invented in those days
were gonna screw up the experiment.
Turns out they didn't,
but it was electromagnetically
quiet, so quiet inside there
that Dave Schuster
could sleep standing up.
(audience laughing)
Okay, so...
what we did in in in this
paper led by Alexandre Blais,
a theory paper was to get
rid of all the DC stuff
and send in microwaves
in, get microwaves out.
And I didn't understand, you know,
as a condensed matter physicist,
I didn't know anything about quantum
measurements in those days.
I had to learn this.
And this really is sort of the
prototypical quantum measurement,
you send in the microwaves
they come back with a phase shift
that depends on the
frequency of the cavity,
which in turn depends on
the state of the qubit.
And so you literally entangle
the qubit with a meter,
the photons, and then
you read out the meter.
And I learned so much
from finally understanding
quantum measurements
from thinking about this.
It was a really wonderful time.
So Andreas
and Dave managed to get
the vacuum Rabi splitting
for the first time in a circuit.
And I remember when trying to calculate
how big was it gonna be and
you know, get the units right
and everything, and it came
out a hundred megahertz
and I thought, oh my gosh,
that's pretty gigantic.
But then, you know, there was charge
noise and it was horrible.
But they managed to...
to get at work sneaking in
at night when things were,
the elevator wasn't running or something.
and that worked
and that illustrated strong
coupling that the coupling,
the dipole coupling was
bigger than the dissipation.
Then Dave
and Jay went into the limit
where the second order effects
of the coupling, the dispersive
coupling were still so big,
they were bigger than the dissipation.
And then you could count individual
microwave photons proving
that they really are particles not waves
and also could see this
Purcell suppression.
Hanhee Paik did a 3D cavity experiment
and Matt Regor worked on making these
cavities much longer lived.
And now we have new designs and,
and it's amazing now
the lifetimes you can
get out of these things.
So the Santa Barbara group
started making super positions
of small numbers of photons.
Here's the theoretical Wigner function
and the experimental
reconstructed Wigner function
for zero plus one through zero plus five
from our friends here.
And so we're, you know, and Rob
and company did an experiment
seeing the electric field
between the superposition
of zero and one photons
and we were really into the world
of controlling individual quanta.
And then this first
two qubit quantum processor
with the two qubits talking
to each other through the
quantum bus of virtual exchange
of microwave photons that was developed
in Rob's lab by these guys.
And we were so excited to, you
know, run a quantum algorithm
with two qubits
and okay, it's a start, you
have to start somewhere.
And I think Jerry will
tell us about some minor
scaling up that they've been doing
(audience laughing)
and in the last few years
and we look forward to hearing that
is gonna be exciting.
So here's the gang excited
about two qubit entanglement
and algorithms in 2007.
And Dave doesn't look that excited,
(audience laughing)
but I think he was, I think he was happy.
I don't know.
Okay, so I'm gonna,
that's the past I want to
talk about more recent past
of quantum error correction
and I'm just gonna briefly mention things
with three different
experiments using bosonic codes
which have gotten to
slightly beyond break even
and more recently substantially beyond.
And then I'll say a little bit more
on the theory end later.
So the first code
was the cat code that
was developed by our,
within collaboration
with theory collaborators
and experiment in Rob's lab in 2016
getting slightly above
breakeven using Schrodinger
cat states with the either
super position of two positions
or two momenta.
And then Luyan Sun, who
an alum from here did,
did two nice experiments
using the binomial code,
which Liang Jang
and I threw together as a summer project
with an undergraduate Myers Michael
and got just above breakeven
in the correct conservatively defined way
in 2023.
And in the same issue
of nature of Vlad Sivak
and Michelle's group did a
quantum air correction using
these beautiful grid states, GKP
code words and there was an improved
tantalum transmon, a
reinforcement learning agent
that helped improve this.
And on the theory side, a nice
new semi-autonomous stabilization protocol
that avoided the measurement
and feedback scheme
and all of those things
combined to get us up
to an error correction gain of 2.3.
And really impressively
you could do 400 cycles
of quantum error correction
before losing the information.
So that's really in a class by itself.
Okay, so now I want to turn to the future
and tell you about a few things
that are in this monster
paper that I've been saying
for some time is almost ready.
It's 12 authors, 137 pages, 533 references
and we're still working on it
and it's to try to formalize
in a computer science sense,
some of the instruction set architectures
that experimentalists
now are using to control
hybrid systems consisting
of discrete variable qubits
and continuous variable oscillators.
And this is primarily a C2QA project,
but the Yale part is
also supported by ARO.
So imagine just as a,
you know, a theorist's
hardware architecture that you had a two
or maybe three dimensional
grid of harmonic oscillators
connected by beam splitters,
which unlike optical beam splitters,
they're microwave activated
using three or four wave mixing.
You can turn them on and off
and you can adjust their rate
and their phase to,
to move photons from one box to the other.
And each box has a single qubit
dispersively coupled to it.
And let's compare that to an ion trap.
We're gonna have gates that are similar
to ion traps, spin dependent forces,
but in an ion trap each of
the spins is coupled to all
of the modes and they like to advertise.
This gives them all to all
coupling, but it's complicated
and you have to, you can get crosstalk
and there are various complications
although, you know, still
works extremely well
but there's no controlled
coupling between these modes.
Whereas here you can be talking
to a single mode very
cleanly with no cross talk
and then swap that mode
through here to somewhere else
and have it talk to another qubit
and come back so that you can communicate
and entangle the qubits or the cavities.
So there are sort of three
possible abstract machine models
that this hardware could
present to the software.
It could be qubit centric with the
boons just playing the role
of a communication bust
that's highly controllable
and you could have swapping going this way
and swapping going that way
at the same time, as long
as you schedule the swaps
to avoid collisions.
It could be bosonic mode
centric where the only purpose
of the qubits is
to give you universal
control over the oscillators,
which in turn contain perhaps
quantum error correction
bosonic codes and it could be hybrid
in which you have access
at the software level
to both the discreet variable
and continuous variable degrees of freedom
that could be very good for
quantum simulators for spins
or phormeons coupled to bosons
such as lattice gauge theories,
which is one of the things
that we're working on in C2QA
and some particular version of this
in the dual rail encoding
you'll hear about on Friday.
So in order to program this thing,
you have to produce unitaries.
That's what quantum computers do.
And so here's a short crash course in
control theory for these hybrid systems.
So by driving a two level system
with classical drives, can you control it?
Well in some rotating wave
approximation you get control
of the poly X and the poly Y operators
and there's a fundamental
theorem from control theory
that if the lee algebra of
the available controls defined
by their commutator spans
the space of all operators,
you have controllability
and fortunately the commutator
of the Pauli X and Y gives Pauli Z and
therefore you have able
to generate arbitrary SU2
lead group rotations on this
single qubit using only
two classical controls.
The same is not true for
a harmonic oscillator.
Your two classical drives, cosine
and sine couple you in the
sum rotating frame to position
and momentum and
unfortunately the commutator
of those guys is just a number and
therefore the algebra closes
and you cannot do anything other than
displace the oscillator in phase space.
You can make coherent states
but you can't make fox states
or GKP states or binomial code words.
And we know also physically
that's closely related
to the fact that the
level spacing is uniform.
But in this dispersive
coupling hamiltonian
where you have a qubit
coupled to the cavity
and their frequencies are
different than you get this
dispersive coupling
and by applying drives to the cavity
and the qubit, you can
reduce this nonlinearity
to something slightly
less nonlinear to just X
and P times one of the Pauli matrices.
So if you look at the
commutator algebra for
that set of controls for example X
the oscillator position times Pauli X,
momentum times Pauli Y,
you get something interesting
because the Pauli matrix is anti-qubit
you get conditional squeezing hamiltonian,
it will squeeze the
position if Z is plus one
and squeeze the momentum
if Z is minus one.
If you take further commutators, you see
that the polynomial
grows and grows in degree
and the operator algebra does not close
and you get universal control.
So then knowing that
there are standard tricks,
Trotter-Suzuki to add control terms
and Baker Campbell Hausdorf,
to multiply them in the form
of commutators and you can then
generate the most general Hamiltonian
that a single qubit coupled to
a single oscillator can have,
namely some polynomial of
X and P for the oscillator
and a vector of three
polynomials dotted into
the Pauli system.
And that gives you universal control.
So there are many instruction sets
that we consider in this paper,
but I'll stick to one example here,
which is the control displacement,
which is generated exponentials
of that control set
and plus single qubit
rotations around axes
on the equator of the block sphere.
And by alternating these,
you're doing a kind
of quantum signal processing extended to
where the rotation angles on the
qubit are now quantum objects themselves
that don't necessarily
commute the position
and momentum of the oscillator.
And so here are some examples from
Alec Eickbusch's paper in
the from the Devoret group.
This is the characteristic function for
what is obviously a highly squeezed state.
Here is the same for
the binomial code words.
This is all data and this
is the GKP code words
and these can be made in
very shallow circuits.
This is a very expressive gate set in the
machine learning language.
So what can we do with these?
Well the first thing is
you can do the world's most
complicated single qubit rotation by
doing a series of controlled
and uncontrolled
displacement in such a way
by applying these spin dependent
forces to the oscillator.
If the qubit is in one,
you make a counterclockwise
circuit in phase space
and pick up one berry phase.
And if qubit is zero,
you pick up the opposite.
And the net effect of that is no matter
what was in the cavity before
it's the same, unchanged.
But the qubit gets a phase
kickback, which rotates it
around the Z axis.
And here you can see the
Ramsay fringe oscillations
measuring that rotation.
So can we extend that
to do something interesting
within this qubit
centric abstract machine model
where the cavities do something
to the qubit, not the other way around.
And Kevin Smith has developed a series
of entangling gates, so the RZZ theta,
this two qubit rotation
you can achieve let's say
between this qubit
and that qubit by doing a
control displacement in the first
cavity, then moving the contents
of that cavity down here,
doing a different
control displacement with
that guy, moving it back
and forth a couple of times.
And you can get one
of four trajectories
depending on the four values
of Z1 and Z2.
And if Z1
and Z2 are the same,
you make a clockwise loop either here
or here depending on whether
it's zero, zero or one one.
And if they're the opposite,
you go counterclockwise either here
or here picking up opposite phase and
therefore doing this gate.
Now there are simple...
you could have bigger swap networks so
that you entangle this qubit
with that qubit by swapping
through some path this way.
And unlike Malmer-Sorenson
and ion traps, you don't
do this to everybody.
You select who you do this to
and you can do several
of them in parallel.
Kevin's also found similar
circuits that will produce CNOT
ZZZ of theta, Toffoli gates, et cetera.
So that's a nice example
of using the cavities
as communication bus plus
things that can entangle
the qubits in a qubit centric model.
In a boson centric model, we
want to use the same gate set
to do things to the
oscillators using the qubits
with the same gate set.
And one example is an improved circuit
for GKP bosonic code
stabilization and gates.
And this is what was used
in the first part of this is
what was used in the recent experiment
from Michelle's group.
So I'll just remind you
that the idealized GKP wave functions
are a picket fence,
evenly spaced in position,
and it's where a transform
is a picket fence easily
evenly spaced in momentum.
And these are defined by
stabilizers, two stabilizers,
which are a momentum boost
and a position displacement.
You can see, understand
the displace, you know,
if you displace this
by a lattice constant,
it comes back to itself.
So it's a plus one eigenstate of that.
And so the stabilizers in the code
are translations in phase space.
How do we measure the eigen
value of those stabilizers?
Well, unlike the Pauli
stabilizers you're used to,
they're not plus one or minus one.
They have a phase that
lives on the unit circle
and they're sensitive.
That phase is sensitive to
small displacement errors
of this lattice of states.
And the way you measure the
eigen value associated with
that unitary is with a phase
kickback circuit like this
much as was used
in that Ramsay fringe
experiment I showed you.
So you can reinterpret
this momentum boost when you put a Z there
instead of a momentum boost.
That depends on whether Z
is plus one or minus one.
You can think of it as
a rotation of the qubit
around the Z axis.
That depends on the
position of the oscillator.
And if the positions are on a lattice
and they're in the right place,
that rotation is a multiple
of two pi and doesn't give
you any change in the state
of the qubit.
But if there's an error,
you pick up some signal,
well that's fine for the ideal world,
but in practice you have
to have a Gaussian envelope
and finite squeezing
of these picket fences.
And so there's some quantum
uncertainty in the rotation
angle of the qubit.
And it's not always
exactly two pi multiple
of two pi, even when
there's no actual error
because of this quantum uncertainty.
So that's a problem.
And also, you know, we
have to deal with this fact
that there's an overall Gaussian envelope.
So how do we handle this?
And it's too complicated to explain now,
but there's a wonderful
autonomous protocol rather than
measuring the small shifts,
you run this circuit developed
by these folks where you
have the stabilizer in there
but with a controlled
gate as I showed you.
And then you pre and post
pendat with very small
perpendicular displacement in phase space
which actually turn out if
you choose them correctly,
to cancel out the effect
of these Gaussian
fluctuations in position.
And then rather than measuring
and feedback, you just
reset the qubit or measure
and reset it and it pumps away the entropy
from the system without
having to do direct feedback.
So that was a interesting step forward.
Now if you want to have the GKP code,
and it's interesting fact that
the Pauli unitary like the X,
Y or Z unitaries are just displacement.
They're very easy to do,
whether you just send the classical pulse
and change the position of the oscillator.
But how in the world could we
do a Pauli rotation, let's say
around the x axis, which
is a super position
of not doing a displacement
and doing a displacement.
Those are sort of macroscopically
distinguishable things.
How do you do that?
And it turns out Shada Singh has...
who's working with me in her degree has
modified this small big
small stabilization protocol
that does autonomously,
does the error correction,
it just splits this middle
step into two pieces
and inserts a qubit rotation in between.
So it actually takes almost
exactly the same length
of time as the stabilization process
and the stabilization keeps working.
And so it protects against
photon loss in the cavity
or small phase based displacement.
And it also has some favorable
properties with respect
to the ancilla dephasing errors.
And this looks a little
bit like ordinary gate
teleportation, but actually it's not
because this second half
of the circuit is not the
inverse of the first half.
And so that's something
that's being written up now.
So there are many open questions.
What's the analog of
randomized benchmarking
for continuous variable systems?
there are analogs between
Gaussian operations
and Clifford operations on qubits,
but the Gaussian
operations are non-compact.
They involve Bogoliubov
transformations, not SU2,
they don't form a two
design for the theorists.
Learning how to do this non abelian
quantum signal processing using both
momentum boosts and position displacement
as rotation angles on the qubits.
But is there a formal theory
to give us convergence bounds
on how well that works?
And is there a nice way to construct
useful unitaries other than
numerical optimization?
And we've made some progress on that,
but still lots more work needs to be done.
So this is a very incomplete history
and I just want to say thank
you to the many, many people,
all of whom I can't list here
that I've had the pleasure
of working with recently
inside YQI from postdocs, students,
undergrads, and even
a high school student.
And many thanks to my faculty colleagues
with whom I am working
and to a few more that we're excited
to be recruiting right now.
And finally, it happens
that this month is a
palindromic birthday for Rob
when expressed in binary.
(audience laughing)
And so I want to wish Rob a happy birthday
and thank him for so many years
of just fantastic collaboration.
(audience clapping)
(light ambient music)